apple shares climbing to a new record
high of 121 27 and needs to close above
1 1994 to set at a new all-time closing
high now the company increased the sale
of its Swiss bond debut selling 1.25
billion swiss francs of bonds that's
about 1.35 billion dollars taking
advantage of that country's low interest
rates record low rates remember the
10-year yield in Switzerland not so long
ago turned negative according to people
familiar with the matter Apple is
selling 875 million francs in nine year
notes and 375 million francs in 15 year
notes the implied yield there is about
75 basis points on the 15-year notes and
37 25 basis points for the nine-year
notes we pay attention to this because
apple supposedly according to traders
has a knack for timing the bond market
right it always tends to sell right
before yields hit their lows that's
certainly what happened back in 2013 we
also know that Apple has plenty of cash
it generated 30 3.7 billion dollars in
free cash flow last quarter so all this
cash that's making through this bond
sale probably used to return to
shareholders through buybacks and
dividends